THE ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE IS CALLED TO ORDER --
WITHOUT HAVING A QUORUM WILL
BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
GOOD AFTERNOON PLEASE NOTE THAT
FILE ITEM TO S. B. NINE SIX
SEVEN BY SENATOR BERRYHILL.
WILL BE PRESENTED TODAY BY
MEMBER ACOSTA.
FILE ITEM.
SIX SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION.
TWELVE I SENATOR WIENER WILL BE
PRESENTED TODAY BY SENATOR DOT.
PLEASE NOTE THAT OUR GUIDELINE
FOR BILLS HEARD IN THE COMMITTEE
IS TO ALLOW TESTIMONY FROM TWO
WITNESSES FOR SUPPORT.
AND TWO WITNESSES FOR OPPOSITION.
SPEAK FOR TWO MINUTES EACH.
HOWEVER IF YOU'RE ABLE TO KEEP
TO THE FOUR MINUTE YOU CAN
DIVIDE YOUR TIME AMONG YOUR
WITNESSES.
I WILL ALSO CALL FOR TWEENER
TESTIMONY THOSE WHO ARE NEITHER
IN SUPPORT.
WERE IN OPPOSITION.
AND WE WILL BEGIN BUT SENATOR
DODD [inaudible]
WELCOME CENTER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
WELCOME.
AND THE MEMBERS.
I AM PROUD TO PRESENT S. B. FIVE
SEVEN SEVEN TODAY WHICH
ESTABLISHES THE CALIFORNIA KEEP
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TEACHER
CREDENTIALING.
PARTNERSHIP PILOT PROGRAM.
IT'S QUITE A MOUTHFUL.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN --
IN HIS COMMITTEE STAFF.
IN THE NUMEROUS STAKEHOLDER
GROUPS FOR THEIR HARD WORK
THROUGH THE INTERIM.
OF THIS PROPOSAL ON HELPING ME --
CRAFTY -- A
BILL THAT I THINK REALLY MAKES A
LOT OF SENSE.
I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN
THE COMEDIANOUT A ANALYSIS.
ACCORDING TO A RECENT REPORT
FROM THE LEARNING POLICY
INSTITUTE 75% OF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS REPORT.
TEACHER SHORTAGES.
IT'S ESTIMATED THAT SCHOOL GOING
POPULATION WILL INCREASE BY
ROUGHLY THREE MILLION STUDENTS
IN THE NEXT DECADE.
NEW TEACHING CREDENTIALS IN
CALIFORNIA REMAINED FLAT THE
PROJECTIONS SHOW THE NEED FOR
NEW TEACHERS A CALL IS ECLIPSING.
AN ADDITIONAL HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
THE THOUSAND TEACHERS.
ON TOP OF STANDARD HIRING NEEDS
OVER THE NEXT DECADE.
AS A FATHER GRANDFATHER I TRULY
BELIEVE THAT EDUCATING FUTURE
GENERATION IS OUR MOST IMPORTANT
DUTY WE NEED TO DO A BETTER JOB
OF ATTRACTING RETAINING HIGH
QUALITY TEACHERS.
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
OUTSTANDING RESOURCES THAT CAN
HELP MEET THE GROWING NEED FOR
TEACHER TRAINING CREDENTIALING
ESPECIALLY IN THE UNDERSTAND.
SERVE RURAL AND URBAN
COMMUNITIES THAT WOULD BENEFIT
THEM THE MOST FACE TO FACE
INSTRUCTION.
THIS BILL HELPS ME CALIFORNIA'S
TEACHER SHORTAGE.
S. B. FIVE SEVEN SEVEN ADDRESSES
SIGNIFICANT WORKFORCE NEEDS BY
REMOVING A CRITICAL BARRIER.
RESPECTED TEACHERS IN RURAL
AREAS ARE OFTEN UNABLE TO TRAVEL
OR RELOCATE TO ATTEND A
CREDENTIALING PROGRAM.
WITH ME HERE TODAY I'M PLEASED
TO INTRODUCE.
DOCTOR DOUGLAS HOUSTON THE
CHANCELLOR OF YUBA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT AND MARK
MCDONALD REPRESENTING NUMEROUS.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU I CHAIR
MEMBERS MARK MCDONALD MCCALLUM
GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE KERN --
IN FOOTHILL DE ANZA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS AND SUPPORT I
WANT TO THANK YOU CHAIRMAN FOR
HOLDING THE HEARING --
THANK CS YOU FOR WORKING WITH US
ON THIS AND THANK YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF.
BOB FOR HIS TREMENDOUS WORK THIS --
BILL REALLY COMES OUT WELL --
WHERE WE MOVED FROM ALLOWING
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS TO
OFFER?
TEACHER CREDENTIALING PROGRAMS
WHICH WAS SOMETHING THAT THERE
WAS NOT SUPPORT FOR TO LOOKING
AT PARTNERSHIPS WHICH IS
SOMETHING WHERE --
THERE SEEM TO BE SUPPORT AT THAT
HEARING --
WERE IN SUPPORT APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT --
I'D LET YIELD MY TIME HERE THE
REST OF IT --
TO DR DOUG HOUSTON CHANCELLOR
YUBA COLLEGE.
GERMANY THAT MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND STAFF AYE LIKEWISE
WOULD LIKE TO ECHO MY
APPRECIATION --
FOR THAT THE CONVERSATIONS THAT
WE HAD AT THE PANEL HEARING THAT
YOU HAVE LAST DECEMBER --
AS I THINK YOU MAY RECALL --
DURING THAT TIME SINCE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE CSU ASSISTANT
VICE CHANCELLOR FOR TEACHER
PREPARATION.
DOCTOR MARQUITA GRENACHE IRE NOW
WE HAVE COMMITTED --
TO DEVELOPING A POLICY FRAMEWORK
FOR CSU AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PARTNERSHIPS THAT WOULD EXTEND
THE TEACHER CREDENTIALING
PROGRAMS IN TEACHER PREPARATION
AND RURAL COMMUNITIES.
AS YOU'RE AWARE THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF EXISTING CSU AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PARTNERSHIPS
THAT PROVIDE PATHWAYS FOR
TEACHER EDUCATION.
I AND THE INTO TEACHING CAREERS
BUT THEY ARE ALL IN LOCATIONS
WHERE THERE IS A A CS YOU. FOR
PRIVATE INSTITUTION AND A
COMMITTEE COLLEGE IN CLOSE
PROXIMITY.
AND WHAT THIS INITIATIVE WOULD
DO WOULD BE UP TO PROVIDE THAT
POLICY FRAMEWORK AND RESOURCES.
TO EXTEND PARTNERSHIPS LIKE THAT
IN THE DISTANT PARTS OF OUR
STATE IN THE WORLD COMMUNITIES
WHERE THERE IS NO ACCESS TO
TEACHER PREPARATION PROGRAMS.
SO AGAIN I PRE SHE ATE ALL OF
YOUR INSIGHT AT THE PANEL
HEARING AND I APPRECIATE THE
PARTNERSHIP THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO FORGE WITH A CSU LEADERSHIP.
AND A WHOLE HEARTEDLY RECOMMEND
THAT YOU ENDORSE THIS INITIATIVE
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
AND EIGHT WINNERS.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ALEX CRAZE OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY I WITH THE
RECENT MOMENTS WERE VERY HAPPY
TO REMOVE OUR PRIOR OPPOSITION
WE ALSO LIKE TO THANK SENATOR
DIED HIS STAFF.
AS WELL AS THE VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS FOR ALL THE
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD THROUGH
THE FALL AND THE SPRING TO
CREATE A FRAMEWORK THAT WE THINK
AYE IS REALLY EXCITING AND
INTERESTING IN THAT WE THINK.
BOTH --
RECOGNIZES THE THE EXISTING
ACCREDITED PROGRAMS THAT CSU --
PRIVATE NOT FOR PROFITS ETCETERA --
WHILE ALSO ADDRESSING NEEDS AND
LOCAL.
GOOD AFTERNOON AS CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS TOM WHO WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES WE ARE THE
ORGANIZATIONAL VOICE. FOR
SEVENTY EIGHT INDEPENDENT
PRIVATE NONPROFIT COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
OF LIKE OUR CSU COLLEAGUES WE
ARE ALSO REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL --
WE DO NOT HAVE A POSITION ON
THIS NEW VERSION OF THE BILL YET.
A WE ARE STILL GOING THROUGH OUR
PROCESS EASE BUT WE DO BELIEVE
THE FRAMEWORK IS SOMETHING THAT
WE CAN WORK WITH.
AND WE DO A LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND AT THE
AUTHOR --
AND REACHING UP --
VERSION THAT WE CAN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHRIS IN THE
HEAD CENTERS ON BEHALF OF THOSE
AT NUMBER IF LIKE ME BECAUSE
THEY'VE CALIFORNIA --
PLEDGES FOR NOT COMING IN
EARLIER BUT WE ARE ARE HERE IN
PRESIDENT FOR AND SUPPORT
THINKING.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
JOBS.
YEAH AND I REALLY THINK THE AREA
MAKE --
CENTER DODD GRANT FOR BECAUSE
THE TEACHER SHORTAGES SERIOUS WE
KNOW PROBABLY WHEN BETTER THINGS
WE NEED TO DO IS.
ONE INCREASE OUR IMAGE OF THEM
BUT ALSO TO PAY SO FOODS ARE
GOING THAT DIRECTION.
BUT IN A MATTRESS IN THIS
PROGRAM NIGHT BECAUSE WE HAD
STARTED A FEW YEARS AGO.
WITH THE A BA IS A COMMUNICABLE
INCH.
AND WHAT WE FOUND THAT DUE TO
SOME QUEUE MANY COLLEGES DOING
REALLY WELL WITH THAT SOME.
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE APPLY
AND IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WITH ANY COMMUNICABLE ADJUST IT
TOOK ONTHAT REQUIREMENT TO GIVE
WOULD BE A THERE WERE SEVERAL
YES.
YOU KNOW WHAT'S BEEN THE RESULT
OF THEM.
MY MY UNDERSTANDING IS --
WHERE THE --
THERE'VE BEEN --
BA'S THAT --
DISTRICTS OF TAKING ON THEY'VE
GENERALLY BEEN SUCCESSFUL --
I THINK WE HAD OUR FIRST A GROUP
OF GRADUATING CLASSES JUST THIS
PAST --
SPRING --
THERE WAS A LOT OF I KNOW THERE
WAS A LOT OF MEDIA COVERAGE OF
THOSE.
AND AND THOSE PROGRAMS HAVE
DEFINITELY BEEN SUCCESSFUL.
WHEN I SAW BEFORE THAT SOME OF
THEM IN THE NORTH WERE NOT
SUCCESSFUL AT LEAST THE NUMBERS
WHEN?
IT FALLS FAR AS INVESTMENT.
SO WHAT AS THIS BILL GOES
FORWARD MAYBE THERE SHOULD BE
SOME BENCHMARKS IN STANDARD SAY
THAT.
THERE'S ACTUALLY A MARKET FOR
THIS YOU KNOW WE'RE GOING
PROVIDE THIS.
YOU KNOW BUT I THINK IT'S A GOOD
IDEA TO TRY IT'S A PILOT PROGRAM --
CALIFORNIA'S LARGE STATE ONE
SIZE DOESN'T FIT ALL.
AND HAVE A GREAT RESPECT FOR THE
DOCTOR ARE YOU SO IF HE'S.
TRYING TO DO THIS OUT THERE YOU
KNOW.
GIVEN THE CHANCE TO DO IT BUT I
THINK.
MAYBE IN A MEMBERS LOOK AT SOME
WAYS IS ACTUALLY.
IS A MAKE IN A SENSE FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BUT SO MUCH
RESOURCE INTO SOMETHING THAT.
MAY HAVE YOU KNOW NOBODY WANTS
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IT.
AS ONE MIGHT COME AS COULD BE NO
THE BE A HAS.
BEEN WORKED OUT AS WELL AS WE
THOUGHT THEY WOULD A FEW YEARS
AGO [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING --
THE BILL FORWARD FOR EXCEPT IN
THE AMENDMENTS FOR ALL YOUR HARD
WORK.
I AGREE.
WITH YOU AND WITH MISTER CHAVEZ --
CERTAINLY REALIZE THE SHORTAGE
OF TEACHERS AND EVERYTHING WE
CAN DO.
TO HELP ALLEVIATE THAT --
IS A WORTHWHILE --
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM YET SO WE
WILL WAIT FOR OTHER MEMBERS --
FOR MOTION --
AND THEN WE CAN GO ON TO THANK
YOU I CAN DO CENTER WINNERS ACR
[inaudible]
CLICK YES.
SJR FILE ITEM SIX I KNOW THAT
HOUSE [inaudible]
I GOOD MORNING GOOD AFTERNOON I
SHOULD SAY MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SENATE RESOLUTION NUMBER
TWELVE BY SENATOR WIENER CALLS
OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
RESULT RESTORE FULL FUNDING. TO
THE FULL BRIGHT U. S. STUDENT
PROGRAM.
THE FULL BY PROGRAM DESIGNED TO
INCREASE MUTUAL UNDERSTANDING
BETWEEN THE PEOPLE THE UNITED
STATES IN THE PEOPLE OF OTHER
COUNTRIES IS A FLAGSHIP
INTERNATIONAL EDUCATIONAL
EXCHANGE PROGRAM.
SPONSORED BY THE U. S.
GOVERNMENT.
FOUNDED BY U. S. SENATOR J.
WILLIAM FULBRIGHT IN NINETEEN
FORTY SIX IT IS KNOWN IS THE
GOLD STANDARD IN INTERNATIONAL
EDUCATION EXCHANGE FOR STUDENTS
SCHOLARS TEACHERS PROFESSIONALS
SCIENTISTS.
AND ARTISTS.
ALUMNI INCLUDE EIGHTY TWO
PULITZER PRIZE WINNERS FIFTY
SEVEN NOBEL PRIZE RECIPIENTS IN
THIRTY THREE HEADS OF STATE AND
TEN MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS PROPOSED
THE 71% CUT TO THE FULL BRIGHT.
PROGRAM APPROPRIATION FUNDS THIS
RESOLUTION SIMPLY URGES THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO RESTORE
THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS.
THAT WAS PREVIOUSLY COMMITTED TO
THE FULBRIGHT PROGRAM.
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU
SO MUCH I'M BRADY FOR TREATING
CENTER WINTERS LIVES THAT
DIRECTOR.
OF THIS PROGRAM MEANS A GREAT
DEAL TO BOTH MEN TO CENTER
WINNER --
WE'RE BOTH AWARDED FULBRIGHT
SCHOLARSHIPS AFTER COLLEGE
SENATOR WIENER TO STUDY ABROAD
IN CHILE FOR URINE AND MYSELF A
TEACHER UNIVERSITY AND COLUMBIA
FOR YEAR.
AND BOTH OF US I THINK OF USE
THAT THAT EXPERIENCE IS A SORT
OF PIVOTAL MOMENT TO FIND
HERSELF IN PUBLIC SERVICE SO.
WE'RE JUST URGING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT --
RESTORE FUNDING TO THIS CRUCIAL
PROGRAM [inaudible]
COLUMBIA.
THE WINNERS OF THE CUP AND
BECAUSE THEY HANNAH WE VIA
FORMER PEACE CORPS VOLUNTEER
COLUMBIA [inaudible]
THANK YOU --
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE WELL.
LET ME SAY ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
AND EIGHT WINNERS NOT SEEN ANY.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU AT I'D UP APPRECIATE
THE RESOLUTION BUT I I THE TWO
ENTERED FIFTY TWO MILLION IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY NINETEEN
THAT'S THAT'S THE AMOUNT OR THIS
RESOLUTION TO BE ASKING CONGRESS
TO RESTORE [inaudible]
THAT RIGHT.
SO PREVIOUSLY THE PROGRAM HAD
BEEN FUNDED OR ROUGHLY LEVEL OF
TWO HUNDRED FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS SINCE TWENTY TEN IN REAL
DOLLARS IT'S SEEN A DECLINE.
OF ABOUT 17% OVER THE LAST EIGHT
YEARS TWO HUNDRED FIFTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS REPRESENTS 4100%
FUNDING OF WHAT THIS PROGRAM
WOULD HAVE BEEN SKILLED TO OF
HAD BEEN FULLY FUNDED SINCE --
THE PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION
TWENTY TEN OKAY AND IS THAT
THEIR ENTIRE BUDGET DO THEY
RECEIVE PRIVATE --
CONTRIBUTIONS ARE IS THAT I SIT
SPEAK TO THE MATCHING FUNDS THAT
HOST COUNTRIES WOULD OFFER X. I
THINK THERE IS A PORTION OF IT
DEPENDING ON THE COUNTRY
DEPENDING ON THE PROGRAM IN
RESEARCH GRANT.
BUT THE APPROPRIATION THAT COMES
OUT OF THE GENERAL FUND OF THE
U. S. BUDGET HAS HAS BEEN --
THIS SORT OF BASIS FOR THE
FULBRIGHT PROGRAMS FUNDING WHICH
IS THAT MY MONEY INSTEAD.
OF THEM I DO --
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDS ON THE FULL
AMOUNT OF THEIR BUDGET BUT IT'S
IT'S NOT A SMALL AMOUNT I THINK
AND FEDERAL BUDGET TERMS IT
PROBABLY SEEMS LIKE IT IS BUT I
FULLY SUPPORT THE FULBRIGHT
PROGRAM.
AYE I'M MOST CURIOUS AYE AYE
VERY SURPRISED TO SEE IT'S THAT
LARGE AND DOLLAR FIGURE.
I'M IS THE MANY USED FOR IS IT
FOR TUITION IS IT FOR HELPING
THEM FIND HOUSING.
A DO YOU HAVE ANY SENSE OF WHAT
THAT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY TWO
MILLION WOULD BE ASKING CONGRESS
TO PUT BACK INTO THE BUDGET JUST
WHAT WHAT IT GOES TO AND THE
PROGRAM SURE SO A SIGNIFICANT
PORTION OF THE FULBRIGHT PROGRAM
IS BOTH THE HOST STUDENTS UNITED
STATES BUT ALSO. TO ENABLE THEM
TO GO ABROAD TO LIVE --
SEWED MY EXPERIENCE I CAN'T
NECESSARILY.
THE MONEY WAS --
MY MONTHLY STIPEND AND IT WAS
ABOUT A THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH
GOTTEN SO IT WAS EVERYTHING FOR
ROOM AND BOARD TO FOOD TO
TRANSPORTATION SARUMAN BARRED
TRANSPORTATION AND THE AND
SEPARATE FROM SO THE STIPEND.
REMEMBER TRANSPORTATION THAT WAS
IT IT'S ALSO GOVERNMENT SEVEN
OKAY.
WELL THANK YOU AS JUST A LITTLE
BIT OF MORE ORIENTATION THAT
REALLY ASKING CONGRESS AND I
SUPPORTS TODAY I WANNA MAKE SURE
WE UNDERSTAND.
WHAT WE'RE ASKING TO DO WHERE IT
FITS IN WITH THE OVERALL BUDGET
OF THE PROGRAM?
AND I'M WHAT OTHER OTHER
COUNTRIES ARE EXPECTED TO
CONTRIBUTE AND OTHERS TO
PARTICIPATE AND HAVE A STEAM
PROGRAM LIKE THAT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT IT BE A SHARED.
DUTY SO THANK YOU.
AND WILL YOU WILL --
AS THE SECRETARY TO CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
MEDINA PRESENT [inaudible]
BAKER [inaudible]
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
CHAVEZ [inaudible]
IRWIN [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
LET LOW PATTERSON QUIRK SILVA
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO WEBER.
QUORUM IS PRESENT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
I I WON I THINK --
SENATOR WIENER FOR BRINGING THIS
OF FORWARD --
HAVING BEEN A TEACHER.
I'M VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE
FULBRIGHT PROGRAM IT IT IT.
ACTUALLY EXISTS.
FOR A UNIVERSITY LEVEL
PROFESSORS AS WELL AS HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHERS.
AND I'VE KNOWN SEVERAL HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHERS --
WHO'VE TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF IT IT
GOES BOTH WAYS.
IT SENDS AMERICANS ABROAD AND
BRINGS --
STUDENTS AND TEACHERS FROM
ABROAD TO THE UNITED STATES AS
WELL.
AND IT IS DEFINITELY THE PREMIER --
FOREIGN --
WAY OF PROVIDING --
FOLKS WITH OVERSEAS EXPERIENCE --
IN RESEARCH --
AMONG THE MANY PROGRAMS THAT
EXIST --
WOULD ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
MOVED BY DOCTOR RUMBULA SECOND
BY MS QUIRK SILVA.
A MADAM SECRETARY OF YOU'D CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS BE ADOPTED AND GO
TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR MEDINA AYE
AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM BLOOM AYE
SHOWBIZ.
CHAVEZ I IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY LEVINE LOW.
PATTERSON QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO WEBER.
ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT WE LEAVE
IT OPEN BAKER ABSENT MEMBERS CAN
WE GO BACK AND GET A MOTION FOR
THE FIRST BILL [inaudible]
MOVED BY.
MISTER CHAVEZ SECOND BY MS IRWIN.
MADAME SECRETARY OF YOUR CALL
THE ROLL THE MOTION IS DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE SHOWBIZ SHOWBIZ AYE
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
LEVINE LOW PATTERSON QUIRK SILVA
AYE QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO
WEBER. ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT.
WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD.
WE'LL GO TO ITEM THREE DOCTOR
PATH.
WELCOME DOCTOR VAN.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON I
BELIEVE THAT I HAVE TWO ITEMS AS
THIS SB NINE SIXTY EIGHT CORRECT
YEAH.
OKAY THANK YOU --
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS.
S. B. NINE SIXTY EIGHT REQUIRES
THE COMMUNICABLE JUST A STATE
COLLEGES TO MEET A RATIO OF ONE
LICENSED MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELOR
TO EVERY ONE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED STUDENTS.
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA IS
ENCOURAGED TO MEET THE SAME
RATIO AS BE NINE SIXTY EIGHT
HOPES TO REMEDY THE GENERAL LACK
OF CONSISTENT REPORTING
THROUGHOUT THE SYSTEM THE MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS BY REQUIRING EACH
CAMPUS REPORT THE LEGISLATURE
EVERY THREE YEARS.
THROUGH THE USE OF A SURVEY AND
REPORT ANNUAL ATTEMPTED SUICIDE
DATA WINNER STAND THAT THE BOARD
BEHAVIOR SCIENCES WOULD LIKE TO
COUNT ASSOCIATES AND TRAINEES
TOWARD THE RATIO.
ALSO LIKE TO NOTE THAT S. B.
NINE SIXTY EIGHT DOES NOT LIMIT
THE CS USE ABILITY TO LIMIT PAID
OR UNPAID ASSOCIATES ARE
TRAINEES THIS BILL ONLY SET THE
MANY M. A MINIMUM RATIO FOR
LICENSED MENTAL HEALTH
COUNSELORS.
MIGHT AS MENTAL HEALTH
COUNSELORS ALSO ALREADY HAVE A
HIGH CASELOAD AND SUPERVISING
ASSOCIATES AND TRAINEES ADD TO
THAT -- WE
WOULD BE CONCERNED THAT BY
ADDING ASSOCIATES TRAINEES THE
CAMPUS IS WOULD BRING THEM.
ON IS EITHER CHEAPER LABOR FREE
LABOR WE DO NOT WANT TO ACTUALLY
DECREASE ACCESS TO LICENSE
MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELORS WHAT
THE SAME TIME I INCREASING THE
CURRENT MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELOR
WORKLOAD.
THERE'S A GROWING NEED FOR A
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND S. B.
NINE SIXTY ADDRESSES THE MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS FACING
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM WHILE ALSO
GIVING US THE INFORMATION NEEDED
TO CONTINUE.
GIVING THE CARE OUR STUDENTS
DESERVE AS BENIGN SIXTY IT HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT NO OPPOSITION
FORM OPPOSITION I SPECT WE ASK
FOR AND I THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
GOOD AFTER.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEDINA AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON
HIGHER EDUCATION I'M DOCTOR MIMI
BOMBER SPOCK I'M A CLINICAL
PSYCHOLOGIST FROM CHICO STATE
UNIVERSITY.
AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION.
COUNSELING CENTERS IN THE CSU
ARE CHRONICALLY UNDERSTAFFED WE
NEED S. B. NINE SIXTY EIGHT TO
ENSURE OUR STUDENTS ARE SAFE AND
ARE STAYING ON TRACK TO GRADUATE.
ANXIETY AND DEPRESSION ARE
RAMPANT AND INCREASING AMONG
COLLEGE STUDENTS BOTH HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE NATION.
STUDIES SHOW THAT THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS SEEKING A MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES IS
UP 30%.
MANY STUDENTS PRESENT IN CRISIS
UNABLE TO FUNCTION AND WE CAN
AND MUST DO SOMETHING ABOUT THIS.
S. B. NINE SIXTY EIGHT IS ABOUT
ADEQUATE STUDENT COUNCIL RATIOS.
THE INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
COUNSELING SERVICES THE
ACCREDITING BODY FOR COLLEGE
COUNSELING CENTERS RECOMMENDS A
MINIMUM OF ONE COUNSELOR
410-002-1500 STUDENTS THAT'S A
MINIMUM.
YET IN THE CSU ON SEVERAL CAMPUS
WE HAVE ONE CANCER 430-002-4000
STUDENTS.
THIS UNDER STAFFING IS REAL AND
IT IS DANGEROUS. SEVEN SUICIDES
OCCURRED ON ONE OF THESE
UNDERSTAFFED CAMPUSES DURING THE
PAST WINTER QUARTER.
TREATMENT IS EFFECTIVE YET
COUNSELORS IN THE CSU ARE
STRUGGLING TO BE SURE STUDENTS
ARE GETTING THE TREATMENT THEY
NEED.
HIGH RISK STUDENTS ARE
PRIORITIZED BUT THAT LEAVES MANY
WAITING FOR HELP.
STUDENTS WAIT WEEKS AND
SOMETIMES MONTHS FOR TREATMENT
AND BY THEN STUDENTS TELL US
IT'S OFTEN TOO LATE.
I AM VERY TROUBLED BY THE
STORIES FROM STUDENTS I MET AND
THE CAMPUSES AND DURING RECENT
VISITS AND THEY ARE IMPLORING US
DO SOMETHING ABOUT THIS PROBLEM.
I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THOSE
STUDENTS.
IGNORING THE STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS MUST STOP WE MUST
MEET MINIMUM STAFFING RATIOS
RECOMMENDED BY EXPERTS.
WE CAN NO LONGER CONTINUE TO
SHORT CHANGE STUDENTS WITH
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS WE KNOW FROM
RESEARCH THAT PROVIDING ADEQUATE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES PAYS FOR
ITSELF.
WE KNOW THAT COUNSELING LOWERS
DROPOUT RATES ENHANCES
GRADUATION RATES AND CONTRIBUTES
TO THE FINANCIAL WELL BEING OF
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA AND
BEYOND.
I URGE AWAY THE REAL COSTS OF
IGNORING SUCH AN OBVIOUS
SOLUTION MANAGEABLE AND SAFE
COUNSELOR TO STUDENT STAFFING
RATIOS I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF SB.
NINE SIXTY EIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON --
COMMITTEE CHAIR MEDINA AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS GEORGE RUSSO --
THE ASSISTANT EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THE CAL STATE SENATE SOCIO
XIN.
I'M WE'RE THANKFUL FOR SENATOR
PANS CFA.
AND LEADERSHIP ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE.
SINCE THEN THE CAL STATE SYSTEM
HAVE A HOST OF ISSUES THAT
THEY'RE DEALING WITH RIGHT NOW
HOMELESSNESS FOOD INSECURITY --
AND THE POLITICAL CLIMATE AND
THIS COURSE HAVE CREATED AND A
NUMBER OF ENVIRONMENTAL
CHALLENGES FOR STUDENTS MENTAL
HEALTH --
THAT ISN'T NOW CONSTANTLY BEING
CHALLENGED.
IN FACT THE ISSUE OF MENTAL
HEALTH RESOURCES ON OUR CAMPUSES
HAS BECOME THE NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY OF OUR STUDENTS IN THE
CSU.
EACH YEAR CSSA --
CREATES A POLICY AGENDA TO GUIDE
OUR STUDENTS WORK FOR THE YEAR
THIS YEAR THOSE FOR POLICY
PRIORITIES WERE MENTAL HEALTH.
AFFORDABILITY SAFE INCLUSIVE
ENVIRONMENTS AND EQUITY IN
STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT --
AZERSUN LEADERS WERE CONSULTING
WITH THE ASSISTANCE AT LARGE
THEY FOUND THAT THE NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY THE ISSUE THAT OUR
STUDENTS CARED MOST ABOUT WAS
MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES ON
CAMPUSES MORE SO THAN
AFFORDABILITY.
MORE SO THAN ANY OTHER ISSUE.
AND IT'S EASY TO UNDERSTAND WHY
THIS IS BECOME SUCH A PRESSING
ISSUE ON OUR CAMPUSES JUST UNDER
HALF OF OUR TWENTY THREE CSU
CAMPUSES HAVE A MENTAL HEALTH.
COUNSELOR TO STUDENT RATIO THAT
IS -- NEAR
OR BELOW THE PROPOSED RATIO IN
S. B. NINE SIXTY EIGHT SMITH ON
A MAJORITY A CAMPUS IS STUDENTS
ARE REPORTING SIGNIFICANT WAIT
TIMES TO SEE A COUNSELOR.
SOMETIMES UP TO A MONTH AND CAPS
ON HOW MANY TIMES THEY CAN SEE A
COUNSELOR AND YEAR SOMETIMES AS
LOW AS FIVE TIMES PER YEAR --
THAT'S WHY PASSING S. B. NINE
SUCCEEDED SO CRUCIAL IN A
STUDENT CAN ACKNOWLEDGE OUR NEED
FOR MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES THEY
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO WAIT NEARLY A
MONTH. TO SEE SOMEONE ESPECIALLY
GIVEN THE FACT THAT MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES CAN PRESENT REAL
IMMEDIATE SAFETY CHALLENGES FOR
STUDENTS IN THE STUDENTS AROUND
THEM --
ADDITIONALLY ON ALL CAMPUSES TO
INFUSE ARE BEING USED TO PAY FOR
THESE MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES
THIS MEANS THAT THE MOST OBVIOUS
WAY TO EXPAND MENTAL HEALTH
RESOURCES ON CAMPUSES ARE TO
INCREASE.
I'M STUDENT CAMPUS BASED FEES --
THIS ONLY COMPOUNDS THE CYCLE OF
AFFORDABILITY AND MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES THEIR STUDENTS ARE
FACING.
AND AS OUR SINS ARE STRUGGLING
WITH SO MANY BASIC AYE NEEDS
ISSUES AS WELL AS THE OVERALL
COST TO ATTEND.
I EXACERBATING WINE ISSUE --
BY INCREASING BY INCREASING
CAMPUS SPACE VIEWS TO SOLVE
ANOTHER ONE IS NOT AN ISSUE AT
ALL OR IS NOT A SOLUTION AT ALL.
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL
FOR CONSIDERING THIS ISSUE AND
URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
KIMBERLY ROSENBERGER WITH
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION PRODUCTS ARE BROTHER AND
SISTER AT THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CO SPONSOR WE
THINK EVERYONE STEP ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES BUT
ESPECIALLY.
AT THE COLLEGE LEVEL REVERSING
AGROUND MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
WHERE CAN I ABOUT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
BRIAN HOW WITH CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WERE IN
SUPPORT.
ANGELIQUE YORK WITH NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS IN
SUPPORT.
MELISSA ANDMO WITH SHAW YOUR
ENTRY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY AND
SUPPORT.
HI THIS IS SUSAN CHAN I'M A
MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELOR AT SAN
FRANCISCO STATE UNIVERSITY.
WHERE WE HAVE ONE COUNSELOR FOR
ALMOST FOUR THOUSAND STUDENTS?
THIS BILL WILL SAVE SO MANY
STUDENT LIVES WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT.
SYNDICATE STAY ON BEHALF OF THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ANY TWEENER.
SEEN ANY ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MOVED BUT I MISS QUIRK SILVA
SECOND BY DOCTOR RAMBLA
[inaudible]
MR JOBS.
YOU KNOW OF FIRST ONSET OF FOR
MENTAL DISORDERS MANY TIMES OUT.
YOUNG MALES BUT THAT TIME
EIGHTEEN TWENTY ONE HAVE THEIR
FIRST [inaudible]
RIGHT.
IN STUDIES SHOW THAT IT --
WHEN THAT FIRST HAPPENED IF YOU
CAN?
DEAL WITH THAT QUICKLY AND GET
HIM THE CARE THEY NEED.
THE LONG TERM ADVANTAGES IS
TREMENDOUS.
YOU DEAL WITH THAT AND IN THIS
ORDER ARE YOU GONNA BE DEAL WITH
THOSE SORTS OF ISSUES.
AS A PROFESSIONAL ECOLOGIST
ABSOLUTELY WERE DOING IT
EVERYDAY.
SO IN YOUR COMMENT IS ABSOLUTELY
TRUE SO THE EARLY INTERVENTION
LEADS TO BETTER OUTCOMES SO THIS --
NOT ONLY SAVES LIVES BUT IT
KEEPS PEOPLE FUNCTIONING AT A
HIGHER LEVEL FOR THE REST OF
THEIR LIFE SO THIS.
HAPPENING AT THIS TIME THIS
CRUCIAL TIME IN AND ADOLESCENT
LATE ADOLESCENCE DEVELOPMENT AS
IS VIC IT'S CRITICAL.
THEN I JUST THOUGHT I BRING THAT
UP BECAUSE BEEN.
THE AS SOME OF YOU ALREADY KNOW
MY SON --
CAME AT FIRST ONSET WHEN HE WAS
A JUNIOR IN COLLEGE.
AND ANY RISK GETS A FRANTIC BUT
BECAUSE OF EARLY INTERVENTION.
HE WAS ABLE TO GO BACK TO
COLLEGE GET A DEGREES GOODNESS
MASSES IN THEOLOGY RIGHT NOW
HE'S FORTY ONE LIVING BY HIMSELF.
TAKING CARE OF HIMSELF.
BUT THAT'S BECAUSE OF THE EARLY
INTERVENTION.
WHEN HE WAS [inaudible] TWENTY
SO -- WANT
TO BRING THAT UP LET PEOPLE TRY
TO HIDE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUE I WE
SPEAK UP ON IT BECAUSE PEOPLE
THINK IT'S A BAD THING WOODS
DISLIKES.
PINCER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU IF.
DO LIKE TO CLOSE DR BEN AND I
RESPECT THE ASININE BUT THANK
YOU.
WELL I I'M GONNA JOIN --
A COLLEAGUE MISTER CHAVEZ --
I ALSO HAVE THE BROTHER.
A BROTHER WHO HAS PROBABLY HAD
HIS FIRST EPISODE OF A MENTAL
ILLNESS AS A JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOL
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT --
AND WAS STILL ABLE TO GRADUATE
HERE AT SACRAMENTO STATE --
SO I WELCOME YOUR COMMENTS AND
WE HEARD UP AND DOWN THE STATE.
THE NEED FOR MORE MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS IN BOTH THOSE CSU
IN THE UC SO I THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR THIS BILL --
WE HAD AT FIRST BY.
DOCTOR RUMBULA SECOND BY MISS
QUIRK SILVA.
AND MADAM SECRETARY IF YOU WOULD
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTIONS DO PASSED THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE SHOT IS.
CHAVEZ I IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY LEVINE
[inaudible]
LOW.
PATTERSON QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO WEBER.
ZERO THE BILL IS OUT WE WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU.
THEN YOUR NEXT ONE IS FILE ITEM
FOR S. B. THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
MEMBERS.
S. B. --
THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT SICKLY
ADDRESSESTHE ALLIED HEALTH
WORKFORCE WHICH IS EXPECTED TO
GROW FROM SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
TO OVER A MILLION BY.
TWENTY THIRTY BUT SOME
ESTIMATING A WORKFORCE SHORTAGE
OF THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND AND
THESE ARE EXCELLENT CAREER SUCH
AS BEING A RESPIRATORY THERAPIST
LICENSED VOCATIONAL NURSE.
RADIOLOGY TECHNICIAN AND
PHARMACY TECHNOLOGIST THESE
CAREERS ARE VITAL TO A
COMPREHENSIVE CARE TEAM TO
SERVER AGING POPULATION.
S. B. THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT
REQUIRES COMMITTEE COLLEGES AND
PRIVATE COLLEGES TO INCLUDE DATA
RELATED TO CLINICAL PLACEMENT
SITES FOR ALLIED HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS. TO THEIR EXISTING
STATE REPORTING THIS MODEST
ADDITIONAL REPORTING STEP ONE
FORM HOW WE CAN EXPAND ALLIED
HEALTH PROGRAMS WHICH ARE
DEPENDENT ON CLINICAL SLOTS SO
IT'S NOT JUST A MATTER OF BEING
IN A CLASSROOM YOU HAVE TO HAVE
CLINICAL EXPERIENCE.
BY PROVIDING A CLEAR PICTURE OF
WHERE THE STUDENTS ARE CURRENTLY
BEING PLACE FOR THE CURRENT
CLINICAL EXPERIENCE AND HOW
THESE CLINICAL PLACEMENTS
CONTRIBUTE TO STUDENT SUCCESS
AND OUTCOMES.
UNDERSTANDING THIS TRAINING
PIPELINE THIS PARTICULAR
IMPORTANCE SO THAT WE CAN
DEVELOP A DIVERSE WORKFORCE
PIPELINE THAT'S REFLECTIVE OF
THE CHANGING DEMOGRAPHICS OF OUR
STATE.
CALIFORNIA'S CURLY FALLING SHORT
WITH ONLY 25% THESE
PROFESSIONALS BEING LATINO
COMPARED 240% LATINO FOR GENERAL
POPULATION AND WITHOUT DIVERSE
PIPELINE OF HEALTH CARE WORK FOR
WORKERS CALIFORNIA WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE CARE DOUBTS BUT
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
APPROPRIATE.
THIS BILL IS CONSISTENT WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS BY THE SENATE
OFFICE RESEARCH WIND WHICH
IDENTIFIED IN A TWENTY TWELVE
REPORT THAT THERE WAS A LACK OF
INFORMATION A CLINICAL TRAINING
SUPPORTS.
THOSE FURTHER RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE LEAD THE CHARGE AND
ESTABLISHING A MEANS TO COLLECT
CLINICAL PLACEMENT DATA AND
EVALUATE SUPPLY AND DEMAND OF
CLINICAL TRAINING PROGRAMS.
CURRENTLY PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS
HAVE ROUGHLY 70% OF THE MARKET
SHARE FOR PROGRAMS WHICH ARE
DIRECTLY DEPENDENT A CLINICAL
PLACEMENT WITH PROVIDERS.
THERE'S A COMPELLING PUBLIC
INTEREST TO KNOW IF THERE'S A
FINANCIAL ARRANGEMENT AS
ADVANTAGE IN PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS OVER A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PROGRAMS.
WITHOUT ADEQUATE DATA
EFFECTIVELY ALIGNED EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS CLINICAL TRAINING SITES
ARE PROJECTED ALLIED HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE DEMANDS OF SHORTAGES
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM OF HIGHER
EDUCATION WILL BE UNABLE TO MEET.
IT'S FUTURE HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE NEED THE STATE.
S. B. THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT WERE
AT SPECIFIED DATA TO EXISTING
REPORTS PROVIDE THE POLICY
MAKERS AND THE PUBLIC BY
COMMITTEE COLLEGES AND PRIVATE
COLLEGES SPOTS A BOWL FOR ALLIED
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS EDUCATION.
I BET WITH THE OPPOSITION AND
THE SPONSORS I CONTINUE WORK OF
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND THE
BUREAU OF PUBLIC IN POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION TO ENSURE
THAT THE REPORTING IS THAT.
AYE TO A ONEROUS COOPER STILL
PROVIDING IMPORTANT INFORMATION
FOR STUDENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR I'VE VOTE AND I AM PLEASED
TO HAVE.
WITNESSES A SUPPORT MR DONVAN
LIGHTNIN FROM THE FACT THE
ASSOCIATING.
SHOULD OF CALIFORNIA AND THEY
CAN REALLY ROSA BROKE FROM THE
S. YEAH YOU TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU AWARE HOW TO BE HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE WORKERS ON THIS
IS A GOOD STRONG MIDDLE CLASS
FIELD AND YET DESPITE THAT WE
ARE SEEING A WORKFORCE SHORTAGE
THAT IS GROWING A DRAMATIC READ --
WE THINK THAT THIS INFORMATION
IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO GATHER IS
THAT WE CAN MAKE INFORMED NEXT
STEPS HERE AT THE LEGISLATURE
AND HOW TO GROW THOSE --
ESPECIALLY BETWEEN THE COLLEGE
LEVEL WHERE IT'S CONSISTENT WITH
A STRONG WORKFORCE PROGRAM --
WE ARE BEING COGNITIVE OF THE
OPPOSITION AND THOSE ALSO OF OUR
AFFILIATES IN SUPPORT BECAUSE IN
ONE FOR THE STREAMLINED WILL
ALSO BE HELPFUL TO US IN
PROVIDING A SOLUTION TO ADDRESS
THE SHORTAGE.
THINK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS JONATHAN LIGHTMAN IN
BEHALF OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IS THE CO SPONSOR OF S.
B..
THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT SO WE SEE
THREE MAJOR --
ARGUMENTS FOR THE BILL FIRST.
IT ALLOWS COLLEGES TO LEARN FROM
ONE ANOTHER WOULD IT'S WORKING
AT THE PLACEMENT SLOTS AND
PROVIDE THEM WITH IDEAS ON
HEALTH FACILITIES WHERE STUDENTS
CAN BE PLACED.
SECONDS AND CONSISTENT WITH THE
SENATE OFFICE OF RESEARCH STUDY
THE DOCTOR PAN REFERENCE THAT
GIVES YOU THE LAWMAKERS.
BETTER INSIGHTS INTO WHAT'S
HAPPENING ALLOWING YOU TO MAKE
INFORMED POLICY DECISIONS MOVING
FORWARD.
AND FINALLY IT GIVES US A BETTER
SENSE OF HOW COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS ARE FARING IN THESE
PLACEMENTS LOTS.
AS LARGEST PUBLIC SYSTEM OF
HIGHER EDUCATION THAT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
SO WE'VE INVESTED A LOT OF TIME
AND RESOURCES ON DEVELOPING THE
STRONG WORKFORCE INITIATIVE AND
INCIDENTALLY THE THEY ACTUALLY
THAT WERE TOUGH THAT HAPPENED
HERE IN THIS COMMITTEE.
AND IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE HAVE A
GOOD SENSE OF WHAT'S HAPPENING
WITH OUR STUDENTS IN THESE HIGH
DEMAND AREAS LIKE.
ALLIED HEALTH I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
RIGHT NOW WITH CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN.
ALRIGHT GO AHEAD ADJUSTING
TELECOM AFTER THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE AND WE DON'T HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION ON THE BILL WE
ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE INTENT
WE'VE HEARD.
ANECDOTALLY FROM COLLEGES ABOUT
THIS ISSUE OF DIFFICULTIES WITH
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS.
WE THINK THIS BILL GO FORWARD
THAT THE QUANTIFY THE PROBLEM WE
CAN.
FIND SOLUTIONS TO AND WILL
CONTINUE WORKING ON AMENDMENTS
AROUND THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
TWEETERS [inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MAP BACK
REPRESENTING CAPS WHICH IS THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PRIVATE POST SECONDARY SCHOOLS
HAVE.
BEEN BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
BEFORE BUT JUST AS A REMINDER WE
REPRESENT ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
INSTITUTIONS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
A WE HAVE MEMBERS IN ALL OF YOUR
DISTRICTS.
I'M SO AND FORCING WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL WE'VE WE'VE
SPOKEN TO THE SENATOR --
ONE WE THINK IT'S DUPLICATIVE
AND THERE'S A LOT OF THIS
INFORMATION THAT'S REQUIRED IN
THIS FORM THAT WE ALREADY
PROVIDE.
A BOW TO THE STATE TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND TO OUR
STUDENTS --
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY WHAT I'VE
I'VE HANDED OUT TO YOU IS A
SCHOOL PERFORMANCE FACT SHEET
TEMPLATE PROVIDED BY THE BUREAU.
AS YOU SEE THERE'S NINE PAGES
THERE THIS IS THE FORM THAT WE
HAVE TO PROVIDE.
I'M AND YOU'LL SEE THAT THERE'S
TWO YEARS OF DATA.
THE GRADUATION RATE THERE'S
DEFAULT RATE --
PERCENTAGE OF BORROWERS THIS IS
ALL VERY SPECIFIED INFORMATION
THAT A SCHOOL CAN USE TO
DETERMINE IF I WANT TO GO TO
SCHOOL A YEAR BE.
A THIS WAS MANDATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND RECENTLY THE
REGULATIONS WERE FORMALIZED BY
THE BUREAU.
SO NOW WE'RE GOING TO ADD TO
THIS NINE TO TWELVE PAGE
DOCUMENT A NUMBER OF THINGS
WE'RE GONNA PROVIDE A LIST OF
ALL OF OUR CLINICAL SITES.
WE TEACH ANYWHERE FROM FIFTY TO
A HUNDRED DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
SOME OF THESE ARE INDIVIDUAL
CLINICAL SITES WHERE A MEDICAL
ASSISTANT STUDENT WILL GO TO
DOCTOR PANTS OFFICE AND LEARN
HOW TO BE A MEDICAL ASSISTANCE
DID.
IT'S NOT A TEAM OF TEN DOCTORS
GOING TO A HOSPITAL IT'S ONE ON
ONE EDUCATION AND CLINICAL
TRAINING.
SO WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF CLINICAL
SITES ONE INSTITUTION CAN HAVE
HUNDREDS OF CLINICAL SITES.
SO THIS NINE PAGE DOCUMENT AT
BEST THAT WE'RE GONNA GIVE TO
STUDENTS IS GONNA HAVE A LIST OF
DOZENS IF NOT HUNDREDS OF SITES.
WE ALSO CONDEMN GOING TO PROVIDE
THE LENGTH AND TYPES OF CLINICAL
ROTATIONS WE PROVIDE THAT IN OUR
CATALOG TODAY IF A STUDENT WANTS
IT.
WE'RE ALSO GOING TO PROVIDE THE
SUPERVISION RATIO AT EACH SITE I
DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH THAT'S GOING
TO ADD TO THE DOCUMENT BUT IT'S
GOING TO ADD TO THE DOCTOR.
WE'RE THEN GOING TO PROVIDE
DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION ABOUT
ALL OF OUR STUDENTS IN THAT
PROGRAM WE PROVIDE DEMOGRAPHIC
INFORMATION TO DAY TO THE BUREAU
AND ALSO TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THROUGH IPADS.
ALL DISCLOSED ALL PUBLIC
INFORMATION.
WE ARE THEN ALSO GOING TO JUST
TO HAVE --
TO REPORT OUR EMPLOYMENT
RETENTION AS THE FORM YOU SEE
THEIR SHOWS WE HAVE TO REPORT.
JOB PLACEMENT TODAY BUT WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO PUT ADDITIONAL
SECTIONS IN THIS FORM.
WE'RE ALSO GONNA HAVE TO TALK
ABOUT WHETHER WE DONATE MONEY TO
THE SCHOOL TO GET PLACEMENT
SITES WHICH IS OFFENSIVE WE DO
NOT BRIBE THESE PLACES TO GET
CLINICAL SLOTS.
SO THIS NINE TO TEN PAGE
DOCUMENT THAT YOU'RE LOOKING IN
FRONT OF YOU IS GOING TO TURN
INTO A THIRTY TO FORTY TO FIFTY
PAGE DOCUMENT.
THAT IS ON TOP OF OUR CATALOG
THAT IS ON TOP OF OUR THIRTY TO
FORTY PAGE ROAMING AGREEMENT
THAT IS ON TOP OF AYE OUR IPAD
STATED THAT IS ON TOP OF THE
SHOPPING SHE THIS IS.
A MORTGAGE DOCUMENT FOLKS WE
HAVE NOW.
LEGISLATED AND REGULATED A
MORTGAGE DOCUMENT FOR A STUDENT
TO PICK A SCHOOL.
SO I THINK IT'S UNFORTUNATE.
AGAIN MOST OF THIS DATA IS HERE.
AND THIS IS THE LAST POLICY
COMMITTEE THAT THIS BILL IS
GOING TO GO BEFORE.
A AS YOU SEE IN THE FORM BEFORE
YOU IT'S TWO YEARS OF DATA THAT
WE HAVE TO PROVIDE THIS BILL IS
COMPLETELY SILENT ON HOW MANY
YEARS OF DATA WE HAVE TO PROVIDE
OF DO WE HAVE TO PROVIDE THE TWO
YEARS OF DATA THAT THE CURRENT
SCHOOL.
SCHOOL PERFORMANCE FACT SHEET
MANDATES.
DO A REPORT LAST YEAR'S COHORT
DO A REPORT ALL THAT THE
CLINICAL SITES THAT WE HAVE
CONTRACTS WITH.
ALL OF THESE IN ALL OF THESE
DETAILS ARE NOT OUTLINED IN THE
BILL AGAIN THIS IS THE LAST
POLICY COMMITTEE THIS BILL IS
GOING BEFORE.
SOME OF THE ASSERTIONS AND THAT
AND THE CLAIMS THAT THE
PROPONENTS WANT FROM THE BILL
THIS IS GOING TO STUDENTS.
THIS ISN'T A STUDY THAT'S GOING
TO THE LEGISLATURE FOR YOU
WALDRON TO COLLECT THAT DATA AND
MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT OUR
CLINICAL SITES THIS IS NOT A
STUDY BILL.
THIS IS REAL LIFE WHAT OUR
SCHOOLS ARE GONNA HAVE TO ADOPT
IT IS EXPENSIVE.
I WOULD ARGUE IT IS DUPLICATIVE
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY ARE
STUDENTS ARE NOT ASKING FOR THIS
INFORMATION.
BECAUSE WHAT WE'RE REPORT TWO
YEARS OUR CLINICAL SITE FROM TWO
YEARS AGO THAT WOULD HAVE TO PUT
IN THIS REPORT IS NOT THE
CLINICAL SITE THAT A STUDENT
THAT IS APPLYING TO DAY IS GOING
TO GO.
TO SO IT'S NOT EVEN THE SAME
CLINICAL SITE.
THAT THE STUDENTS GOING TO
ATTEND A YEAR TO TWO YEARS DOWN
THE ROAD WHEN THEY GET TO THAT
PLACE IN THEIR EDUCATION SO. FOR
ALL OF THESE REASONS WE HAVE TO
OPPOSE THE BILL AND AGAIN THIS
IS THE LAST STOP FOR THIS BILL
AND THERE'S A LOT OF UNANSWERED.
AND I WOULD I WOULD JUST REMIND
THE NEXT WITNESS THAT WE SAID
TWO MINUTES TO WITNESSES AND I
THINK HE WENT OVER FOUR MINUTES
AGO.
IF YOU COULD MAKE IT BRIEF.
THANK YOU JENNIFER TARA HELL
WITH AARON READ AND ASSOCIATES
ON BEHALF OF AMERICAN CAREER
COLLEGE AND WEST COAST
UNIVERSITY.
AMERICAN CREW COLLEGE OPERATING
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
WEST COAST UNIVERSITY OPERATING
SINCE NINETEEN OH NINE HAVE AN
EXCELLENT REPUTATION FOR
PROVIDING TOP NOTCH.
HEALTHCARE CAREER EDUCATION TO
STUDENTS THROUGHOUT LA THE
INLAND EMPIRE AND ORANGE COUNTY.
SB THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT IT'S
CONCERNING TO OUR SCHOOL
SPECIFICALLY FOR SEVERAL REASONS
FIRST OUR SCHOOLS DON'T PAY
HOSPITALS TO PLACE STUDENTS IN
THE CLINICAL INTERNSHIPS NEEDED
FOR LICENSURE.
THE CONTRACT SCHOOLS HAVE WITH
HOSPITALS FOR CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS ARE NOT EXCLUSIVE AND
HOSPITALS ARE NOT AS LIMITED AS
TO WHICH SCHOOLS THEY CAN
CONTRACT WITH.
SECOND LICENSING BOARDS AND AND
APPROVAL OF SCHOOLS PROGRAMS.
DID THAT ENSURES THAT STUDENTS
RECEIVE THE CLINICAL HOURS
REQUIRED TO LICENSING EXAMS.
REQUIRING SCHOOLS TO REPORT
CLINICAL PLACEMENT DATA IN THE
SCHOOL PERFORMANCE FACTSHEET AS
MATT MENTIONED DOES NOT PROVIDE
BETTER OUTCOMES BUT WILL REQUIRE
US TO HIRE ADDITIONAL
ADMINISTRATIVE STAFF. TO PRODUCE
THE DATA CALLED FOR IN THE BILL
THIS DATA WILL BE OUTDATED AS
SOON AS IT'S REPORTED.
OUR SCHOOLS HAVE HUNDREDS OF
CLINICAL PARTNERS AND CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS CONTINUALLY CHANGE
THAT CAN'T BE STRESSED ENOUGH.
THAT THAT PLACEMENTS TO BE
REPORTED ON THE FACT SHEET WILL
NOT REFLECT THE CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS OF POTENTIAL STUDENTS
RECEIVE. ONE SET STUDENT HAS
MADE IT TO THE POINT IN THE
PROGRAM WHERE THEY'RE ACTUALLY
GONNA PARTICIPATE IN CLINICAL
PLACEMENT AND NEXT TO BE PP
<c.green> RECENTLY FINISHED RAGS ON</c>
THIS.
IT SCHOOL PERFORMANCE FACTUALLY
AS MATT HAD MENTIONED SO I WON'T
GO OVER THAT AGAIN.
I'M BUT THERE ARE WAYS TO
RELIEVE PRESSURE ON CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS AND I THINK THAT'S
WHERE A LOT OF THIS IS STEMMING
FROM.
YES THAT THE INDUSTRY THERE'S A
A CALL FOR MORE AND
PROFESSIONALS ENTERING THE
WORKFORCE AND AND THERE'S A
PRESSURE FOR THESE CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS AND WE WELCOME A
DISCUSSION AN OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK ABOUT.
A MORE CLINICAL PLACEMENTS AND
HOW TO RELIEVE PRESSURE FOR
THOSE AND THAT THIS BILL IS NOT
THE WAY TO GO IT WOULD JUST
CREATED ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN
AND I THINK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY.
YEAH I GIVE UP.
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY TWEENER WHO'S.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
SENATOR PAN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
CLOSE.
NO THANK YOU SO MUCH --
NO LIGHTS I APPRECIATE --
THE CONVERSATIONS I HAD WITH THE
OPPOSITION I WOULD POINT OUT IS
THE HEALTH PROFESSION MYSELF AND
SOMEONE WHO SERVED ON A TRADING
BODY NOT ONLY FOR VISION BUT
ALSO FOR ALLIED HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS THAT.
ARE --
CLINICAL TRAINING IS ESSENTIAL
PART OF THE EDUCATION OF AN
ALLIED HEALTH FOR NOTE THAT --
THAT.
SCHOOL THAT IS PROVIDING
CLINICAL TRAINING BECAUSE TALK
ABOUT THE BURDEN OF GATHERING
INFORMATION I SURE HOPE THEY
WOULD KNOW WHERE THAT OUR
STUDENTS ARE GAINED A TRAINING
IN THE QUALITY OF THE TRAINING
THAT'S TAKING PLACE IN THE
CLINICAL SITES.
THEY DON'T HAVE THAT INFORMATION
READILY AT HAND I'D BE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT.
ARE IN FACT --
I'D A SOMEONE WHO SERVED ON THE
GRADING BODY --
AS IT WAS MENTIONED THEY ALSO
FEEL THAT INFORMATION SHOULD
ALSO BE RELIEVED BAILABLE AT
THEIR FINGERTIPS WHEN
ACCREDITING BODY ASKS ABOUT AS
WELL SO.
SO I END.
LITTLE CONCERN ABOUT.
ABOUT BUT THAT PART OF THE
TESTIMONY BUT I WOULD I WOULD
JUST SAY IS THAT IT IS IMPORTANT
FOR US AGAIN AS I SAID BEGINNING
THAT.
THIS INFORMATION IS IMPORTANT
FOR STUDENTS KNOW THE QUALITY
EDUCATION BUT ALSO IMPORTANT FOR
US AND YOU HEARD FROM --
THE COMMITTEE COLLEGES AS WELL
FROM BOTH FACULTY ADMINISTRATION
THAT THEY'VE THAT THAT THIS IS
GOING TO BE IMPORTANT FOR THEM
AS WELL TO HELP US BE SURE WE
HAVE THE STATE CONVENE FORWARD
AND AND PROVIDE THE WORKFORCE
SUPPLY THAT WE NEED. TO TAKE
CARE OF THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONS AND SO AYE URGENT
AYE BUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN --
ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
MOVE BY MS QUIRK SILVA.
SECOND BY MISTER BERLIN --
MADAM SECRETARY IF YOU WOULD
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER NO ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
CHAVEZ SCHABAS NO IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY LEVINE.
LEVINE AYE LOW.
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I SANTIAGO WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER I RIGHT THREE WE WILL HAVE
THAT ON CALL DOCTOR PAN THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT ITEM THREE OR ITEM TO
EXCUSE ME --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ACOSTA FOR
SENATOR BERRYHILL.
FILE ITEM.
TO WELCOME MISTER COST THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEDINA AND MEMBERS.
TODAY'S PRINT THE PRINCIPLE
COOPER I HAVE THE HONOR OF
PRESENTING SB NINE SIXTY SEVEN
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR BERRYHILL
WHO COULD NOT BE HERE TODAY.
ABOUT THIS LEGISLATION SEEKS TO
ELIMINATE ONE OF THE PRIMARY
BARRIERS TO HIGHER EDUCATION FOR
OUR FOSTER YOUTH THE COST OF
TUITION.
THE FOSTER YOUTH ARE MUCH LESS
LIKELY THAN THEIR PEERS TO
ENROLL IN COLLEGE IF THEY
COMPLETE HIGH SCHOOL WHICH FEWER
THAN HALF DO.
THEY ARE ALSO LESS LIKELY TO
GRADUATE FROM COLLEGE IF THEY DO
ONE ROLE.
SEVERAL FACTORS BOTH ACADEMIC
AND NON ACADEMIC CONTRIBUTE TO
THIS GAP IN EDUCATIONAL
SUCCESSES.
FOSTER KIDS DO NOT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO TURN TO THEIR PARENTS
FOR INFORMATION ABOUT COLLEGE
HELP WITH APPLICATIONS FOR
ASSISTANCE WITH THEIR TUITION.
WELL THOSE WHO ARE FORTUNATE
ENOUGH TO BE ADOPTED OUR FORMER
LIKELY TO ATTEND COLLEGE
ADOPTION IS ALREADY AN EXPENSIVE
PROPOSITION FOR THE FAMILIES.
WITHOUT EVEN CONSIDERING THE
COST OF COLLEGE AND FEES.
THIS CAN BE CONSIDERABLE TORRENT
FOR PARENTS CONSIDERING ADOPTION
THOSE WHO DO ADOPT FOSTER
CHILDREN OFTEN DO NOT HAVE THE
SAVINGS IN PLACE FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION.
S. B. NINE SIXTY SEVEN WAR WILL
WAIVE COMMUNITY COLLEGE CSU YOU
SEE TUITION AND FEES FOR FOSTER
KIDS WHO HAVE BEEN IN FOSTER
CARE FOR AT LEAST TWELVE MONTHS.
THE STUDENT WOULD FOOT FIRST OUT
OF THE REQUIRED TO FILL OUT THE
FAST FOR ANY TUITION WAIVER
WOULD TAKE PLACE AFTER GRANTS OR
SCHOLARSHIPS ARE ACCOUNTED. FOR
TWENTY EIGHT STATES ALREADY HAVE
TUITION WAIVER PROGRAMS IN PLACE
AND MOVING THIS BURIED EDUCATION
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO BE A TRUE
GAME CHANGER.
THEN THE LIVES OF SO MANY FOSTER
YOU IN THIS STATE.
WELL CALIFORNIA PRIDES ITSELF AS
A LEADER IN SO MANY POLICY AREAS
IT'S TIME WE FOLLOW THE LEAD OF
SO MANY OTHER STATES THAT HAVE
MADE FOSTER YOUTH THE PRIORITY.
AND GIVE THEM A CHANCE FOR
SUCCESS S. BE NINE SIXTY SEVEN
WILL DO JUST THAT.
THE BILL HAS ENJOYED UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT THROUGH THE SENATE AND I
HOPE WE CAN CONTINUE THAT HERE
TODAY.
I HAVE AT HOWARD WITH THE
CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY INSTITUTE
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT BANK THREE TIME IN
[inaudible]
S. RIVAL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AT HOWARD SENIOR COUNSEL
AT THE CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY
INSTITUTE AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
SAN DIEGO SCHOOL OF LAW THANK
YOU FOR THE MOMENT BRIEFLY TO
ADDRESS YOU ON WHEN --
THE GOVERNMENT COMES INTO OUR
HOMES AND REMOVES OUR CHILDREN
FROM OUR SHARE.
THAT IS PROBABLY THE MOST SICK --
TO OUR GOVERNMENT THERE IS
NOTHING WORSE THAT YOU COULD DO
TO ME -- AS
MY FAMILY THAT TO COME IN AND
TAKE MY AYE DAUGHTER AWAY.
AS A RESULT --
BECAUSE OF THAT WIN THE STATE --
WHEN WE COLLECTIVELY AS THE
STATE REMOVE A CHILD FROM THE
CARE OF THEIR PARENTS WE INCUR A
MORAL RESPONSIBILITY LIKE NO
OTHER -- UP
THE LATITUDE AND LONGITUDE OF
STATE GOVERNMENT.
WE BECOME LITERALLY AND THE
PARENTS OF THESE CHILDREN AND WE
ARE PROPERLY AND FAIRLY JUDGED
BY HOW WELL WE ARE DOING BY THEM.
WHEN THEY GROW UP?
IN THIS INSTANCE WHEN IT COMES
TO COMPLETING HIGHER EDUCATION.
WE EARN A FAILING GRADE.
ACCORDING TO MOST STUDIES
APPROXIMATELY 3% 3%.
A FORMER FOSTER CHILDREN
GRADUATE FROM COLLEGE DID NOT DO
PARTICULARLY WELL IN ARITHMETIC
BUT I DO KNOW HOW TO ROUND.
IF WE WOULD AROUND THAT.
THAT WOULD BE [inaudible]
ZERO NONE.
ARE CURRENTLY GRADUATING.
FROM COLLEGE THESE ARE OUR
CHILDREN.
AND GIVEN OUR UNIQUE MORE
RESPONSIBILITY AND THIS
DISGRACEFUL RESULT THAT CHANGES
ALL IT IS NOT TOO MUCH TO ASK.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHEN
CONSIDERING THE FINANCIAL
OBLIGATION OF THESE CHILDREN
START FROM THE BEGINNING PLACE.
THAT WE WILL NOT IN OUR OWN
INSTITUTIONS CHARGE OUR OWN
CHILDREN MONEY.
AS FOR THE GETTING PLAY.
A THIS IS AN EXCELLENT BILL I
CONGRATULATE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR BEING A CO AUTHOR AND I'M
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE SENATOR
FOR BRING IT FORWARD --
TWENTY EIGHT STATES WE SHOULD BE
THE TWENTY NINTH RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ACTUALLY CORPORATE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
AND SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY TWEENER WHO'S.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
AS SEEN NONE MISTER COSTA WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR OUR
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT S. B..
NINE SIXTY SEVEN OF THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND HOW WE OWE
THESE THESE YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
BEST AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
MOVE AWAY.
CHAVEZ SECOND BY MISTER BLOOM.
I THANK GOD SENATOR BERRYHILL
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
I BELIEVE THE STATE NEEDS AGREED
THAT THE STATE NEEDS TO DO
EVERYTHING IT CAN. TO PROVIDE
FOR THE NEEDS OF OUR FOSTER YOU --
WHO ARE TRYING TO GET A COLLEGE
DEGREE?
I ENCOURAGE THE AUTHOR TO SEEK
TO ADDRESS THE COMMENTS AS
INDICATED.
ON PAGE FOUR OF THE ANALYSIS SO
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
CHAVEZ SECOND BY MISTER BLOOM.
AND MATTER SECRETARY WHO WOULD
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER
[inaudible]
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE SCHABAS.
SCHABAS I IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW [inaudible]
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER I EIGHT ZERO THAT BILL IS
OUT.
AND NEXT UP ITEM [inaudible]
FIVE SENATOR WILL.
IF YOU READ.
YEAH BUT WE HAVE YEAH THAT THAT
THAT WILL HAPPEN HERE
[inaudible]
THE ERA.
YEAH HONESTLY I'VE SHOCKED BY
THAT HIS BUSINESS HERE
MONITORING.
YOU WANNA YOU WANNA WAKE UP
THERE YEAH I KNOW I KNOW I CAN I
CAN DEFTLY WE APPRECIATE IT.
GREAT SO GO.
SO WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DO AB IT
CREATE --
AND A CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE OF
AEROSPACE IT BE HOUSED ON THE
CAMPUS OF ANNA VALLEY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE.
IT BE A CONSORTIUM WITH CAL POLY
POMONA YOU SEE LA NASA AND
AEROSPACE PRIME AYE
MANUFACTURERS THAT A ROUTE.
WITH THE WITH THE GOAL OF DOING --
GRADUATE IMPOSE STOCK AEROSPACE --
CURRENTLY THERE'S FOR THE
CENTERS OF EXCELLENCE ANOTHER
USE ON ACTUALLY AND YOU SEE
CAMPUS IS ONE AND I I T. BIOTECH
NOW TACK.
AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS AND YOU
KNOW THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS
WE ALL KNOW THAT WE'VE LOST A
LOT OF AEROSPACE YOU KNOW OVER
THE LAST TWENTY YEARS.
BUT THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS
AEROSPACE IS STILL LARGER THAN
THAT FILM AND TELEVISION
INDUSTRY AND AGRICULTURE
COMBINED.
AND BY DOING THE RESEARCH HERE
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP OUR HOME
GROWN TALENT HERE.
AND THERE'S NOT ONLY
APPLICATIONS OBVIOUSLY. TO YOU
KNOW AEROSPACE BUT ALL THE
COMMERCIAL APPLICATIONS THAT
HAVE COME OUT OF YOU KNOW
AEROSPACE WHETHER IT'S TEFLON
MEMORY FOAM KIDNEY DIALYSIS L.
E. D. SOLAR PANELS.
SCORES OF OF A ITEMS THAT MAKE
OUR LIVES BETTER EVERYDAY COME
OUT OF THAT SO.
IT'S A FIVE THOUSAND FIVE HER
THOUSAND DOLLAR INVESTMENT THAT
OF THE MATCH FRANKLY BY MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS FROM UP FROM OTHERS.
TED TO CREATE THAT'S AND AND
CREATE MORTGAGE PAINT JOBS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA.
SO WITH ME.
WE HAVE.
TOOK THAT JUSTIFIER.
IN SUPPORT OF THAT TIME MR HERE.
OKAY.
SO NICOLE RICE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURES AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION AND WE'RE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF SB.
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX AND THIS BILL
NOT ONLY WILL IT CREATE A PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP TO SUPPORT
THE LOCAL DEVELOPMENT I THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT OF THE NEXT
GENERATION OF AEROSPACE WORKERS.
BUT I CAN ALSO BOLSTER
CALIFORNIA STANDING AS AN
AEROSPACE HUB BY DRAWING THE
BEST AND BRIGHTEST IN THE
INDUSTRY TO CALIFORNIA TO WORK.
TRAINED TO INSTRUCT AND TO LIVE
AYE WE APPRECIATE THE ANALYSIS
IN THE THOROUGH JOB THAT WAS
DONE BY STAFF AND IDENTIFYING
THE WORKFORCE CHALLENGES IN THE
AEROSPACE MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY
ALSO S. SENATOR WELL BECAUSE I
IDENTIFIED.
AND THE IMPACT THAT IT COULD
HAVE ON CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY IF
NOT ADDRESSED.
AEROSPACE MANUFACTURING IS ONE
OF CALIFORNIA'S BET ROCK
INDUSTRIES SO LET'S DO WHAT WE
CAN TO ENSURE THAT THESE HIGH
PAYING JOBS.
GROW AND REMAIN IN CALIFORNIA SO
WITHOUT I ASK FOR THE COMMITTEES
I FELT THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
AND THE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY TWEENER WHO'S.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
CHAIRMAN.
MR PERHAPS ABSOLUTELY LOVE THE
BILL.
ADAM AND AS OF THE CHAIRMAN OF
THE AVIATION AND AEROSPACE
CAUCUS I'D LOVE TO BE A
COOPERATE.
AND COME DOWN AND SEE IT ALL
WHEN IT OPENS UP.
YEAH YEAH LOVE TO DO THAT YEAH I
MEAN THAT THE BEAUTY OF DOING
AND THEY HAVE A BALLOT BECAUSE
OF ALL THE ASSETS THAT ARE
ALREADY THERE THAT THE DEAD ARE
GRADUATE STUDENTS TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE ACCESS.
TO WIND TUNNELS YOU KNOW
EVERYTHING ELSE BECAUSE WE GOT
ROCKET LAD NASA.
AT EDWARDS AIRFORCE BASE SOME OF
THAT PLAN --
FORTY TWO IN PALMDALE THAT HAS
ALL THE PRIME AND IF ACTORS
BOEING LOCKHEED NORTHRUP.
SO THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE.
ACCESS TO ALL.
EVERYTHING THAT THEY NEED TO
CONDUCT CUTTING EDGE RESEARCH SO
VERY EXCITING.
AT THAT THAT'S NOT A OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
ANY ANY ANY SERIOUS COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS --
MISTER BLOOM.
I JUST WANT TAKE A BRIEF MOMENT
TO THANK YOU --
FOR ALLOWING ME --
TO A SPORT THIS BILL I'D BE
HAPPY TO BE A CO AUTHOR TO WRITE
SAID JUST A FEW DAYS SIR SINCE
FATHER'S DAY AND MY DAD WAS AN
AERONAUTICAL ENGINEER AND I CAN
HONOR HIS MEMORY.
BY BY SUPPORTING THIS BILL BUT
THAT THE REALITY IS THAT --
HE APPLIED HIS TRADE HERE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA --
AT A TIME WHEN AND THE AEROSPACE
INDUSTRY WAS THE INDUSTRY AND
TARA IT HASN'T GONE AWAY
COMPLETELY A LOT OF IT IS --
HAS LEFT MUCH LIKE THE A
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY THAT THE
FILM INDUSTRY WAS ATTRACTED TO
OUT OF STATE WE HAVE TO BE
CONSCIENTIOUS ABOUT TO RETAINING
THE INDUSTRIES THAT ARE.
OTHER IMPORTANT TO THE ECONOMY
OF THE PROVIDE GOOD GUY MIDDLE
CLASS JOBS AND IT'S A PIECE OF
THE ECONOMY THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S
DWINDLING SO.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT WAY OF
DOING THAT WE HAVE ALL THE
PIECES HERE THAT ARE NECESSARY
TO OUT REALLY.
A INCREASE --
WHAT IS ALREADY A THRIVING
INDUSTRY AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
WE OUGHT TO DO YEAH I AGREE WE
NEED TO SUSTAIN ANY THE MEDIAN --
SALARY IN THE AEROSPACE INDUSTRY
IS A IS A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS DOLLARS A YEAR.
AND BECAUSE OF THE WORK THAT WE
DID IN PRIOR SESSIONS WITH THE
WITH THEIR SPACE TAX CREDIT.
NORTHROP WAS ABLE TO CAPTURE
THAT THE NEXT LONG RANGE BOMBER
WHICH IS EIGHTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR CONTRACTS.
SIX JUST IN MY DISTRICT LOANS ME --
SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED JOBS IN THE
NORTH LACKEY JESS WAS AWARDED
THE THE NAME FOR THE TECHNICAL
THE HYPERPLANE HYPE THE
HYPERSONIC PLANE.
AND WE DON'T KNOW THE DOLLAR
AMOUNT OR THE AMOUNT OF JOBS
BECAUSE IT.
BECAUSE IT'S TOP SECRET BUT IT'S
BUT IT'S COMING TO CALIFORNIA'S
WELL.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
[inaudible]
WHAT?
IT WAS THROUGH WHAT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
WE HAD A MOTION BY.
BY MISTER BLOOM --
MISS QUIRK SILVA DID YOU SECOND.
NO ALRIGHT MISTER CHAVEZ SEGMENT --
WANT TO THANK THE OUT THERE FOR
BRING IN THE MEASURE FORWARD AND
VERY PLEASED TO SEE THIS BEING
LOCATED.
IN A COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND I
THINK IT IS CERTAINLY HELP MEET
THE NEEDS OF AEROSPACE AND IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO WE HAD A MOTION BY MISTER
BLOOM SECOND BY MISTER CHAVEZ
MADAM SECRETARY WOULD CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DEEP PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
AYE AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM BLOOM AYE
CHAVEZ.
CHAVEZ I IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW PATTERSON
[inaudible]
PATTERSON I QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER I ELEVEN ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AMBER'S [inaudible]
CENTER [inaudible]
YES.
WE WILL GO TO MEASURES THAT ARE
ON CALL.
ON CALL ITEM NUMBER FOUR S. B.
[inaudible]
THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO LOW [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
BILL THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT SO FOR
THE BILL IS OUT WE WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
NOW TO ADD ON'S ITEM ONE S. B.
[inaudible]
FIVE SEVEN SEVEN KILEY.
KILEY AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW [inaudible]
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE SANTIAGO.
B. -- FIVE
SEVEN SEVEN TEN ZERO BILL IS OUT
WE LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
ITEM.
S. B. FIVE SEVEN SEVEN WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER I THE BILL S. B. SEVEN
FIVE SEVEN SEVEN IT'S ELEVEN
ZERO EVEN IT OPEN FOR ABSENT.
ITEM TWO S. B..
NINE SIX SEVEN BAKER.
BAKER AYE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE LOW [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
THE NINE SIX SEVEN ELEVEN ZERO
WILL KEEP IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ITEM THREE SB [inaudible]
NINE SIX EIGHT KILEY.
KILEY AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW [inaudible]
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I YOU NINE SIX EIGHT
TWELVE ZERO WILL KEEP IT OPEN
[inaudible]
FOR AND MEMBERS.
ITEM FIVE S. B. [inaudible]
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX LOW
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE. THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX
TWELVE ZERO LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM SIX SJR [inaudible]
TWELVE KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING [inaudible]
LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW [inaudible]
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I J. ARE WELL. ELEVEN ZERO
WILL KEEP THAT OPEN.
FOR WE NEED SOME.
CAPITAL BUT REMOVED IT.
SO MISTER DOES TRYING TO GET
HERE.
USE THE RESTROOM COME BACK.
EVEN MISTER SANTIAGO.
OKAY YEAH TELL
.
ITEM ONE S. B. FIVE SEVEN SEVEN
LOW [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE [inaudible]
THE FIVE SEVEN SEVEN TWELVE ZERO
BUT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
WELL WE ARE GOING OKAY.
ITEM TWO S. B. NINE SIX SEVEN
LOW SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE.
THE NINE SIX SEVEN TWELVE ZERO
KEEP IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR S. B. THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT
LOW SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE. THIRTEEN FORTY
EIGHT EIGHT FOUR WILL KEEP IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THAT MISTER SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
CELEBRATE
.
WE'RE HAPPY TO KEEP IT OPEN FOR
YOU WELCOME [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
OKAY YEAH [inaudible]
OKAY.
ITEM ONE S. B. FIVE SEVEN SEVEN
LOW.
LOW AYE.
THE FIVE SEVEN SEVEN TWELVE ZERO
THAT BILL IS OUT. THIRTEEN ZERO
BILL IS A I AM TOO S. B. NINE
SIX SEVEN LOW.
LOW AYE.
S. B. NINTH I'M ITEM THREE SB
NINE SIX EIGHT LOW [inaudible]
LOW AYE [inaudible]
STATE. ZERO THOSE OUT ITEM FOR
S. B..
THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT LOW LOW AYE
[inaudible]
BE THERE FORTY EIGHT NINE
AFFORDABILITY OUT.
ITEM FIVE S. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY
SIX LOW [inaudible]
LOW AYE [inaudible]
BE THERE.
HOUSE ITEM SIX SJR TWELVE LOW
[inaudible]
LOW AYE.
AND I THE J. ARE TWELVE TWELVE
ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT
[inaudible]
AND WE'RE HERE